Alright. We noticed that all of these strings start with a lowercase a and S starts with capital A.
Why don't we have capital A goes to lowercase a just to get rid of this lowercase a at the beginning.
So, we don't have to worry as much about it.
Now, I noticed that there can be some number of b's: bb, bb, one b, so one or more b's here,
and then sometimes, we've got c, and sometimes, we've got c d at the end.
So, I'm going to make B C D be a list of one or more b's, and one way to do that is like this:
B C D goes to b, B C D. So here in the middle, after the a, we could either have no b's
or we could loop as many times as we want and pick up more b's,
and now after that, it looks like we either need c, c d, or nothing.
Well, we have c. We got nothing, so we could also have c d.